in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions
Michelle is with us hey Michelle how are
you I'm great how are you Dave better
than I deserve
where are you from I live in Denver ah
very cool welcome to Nashville hey you
are here to do your debt-free scream I
am I love it very cool Donald now we're
just talking about people doing their
debt free screams so here you are so how
much have you paid off I paid off 37,000
how long did that take nine months way
to go man that's a lot in nine months
what's your income around 120 I'm on a
hundred percent commission based well
I'm actually a headhunter so I placed
management to executive level accounting
and Finance professionals and you're
good at it obviously obviously well done
nice income thank you great so what kind
of debt was the thirty seven thousand it
was mainly the dreaded student loans and
I also had to pay off the rest of my car
and I had a very small credit card
mm-hmm okay so what happened nine months
ago well I had just gone through a
pretty painful breakup and you know
going through the healing process I was
really seeking out God's will for the
pain and the breakup and in doing so I
sought out a lot of spiritual guidance
and pastors that I followed and
listening to podcast and I was fortunate
enough to come across this awesome Andy
Stanley podcast series and starting over
no and I yeah he's fantastic and it made
me realize that I really wasn't trusting
and following God in a few key areas of
my life mmm and that I had some stuff I
need to work on before I would be
prepared to be the person that the
person got intended for me needed in the
future so at that point I decided to
take a year off dating and really focus
on improving those areas of my life and
one key area that I knew I really needed
to work on was my financial health and
at that point I decided to get out of
debt and I jumped in full throttle and
ran after it mm-hmm okay
and how in this process did you find us
you know I was guilty of kinda doing the
Dave Ramsey thing oh you're one of those
one of those yeah a few years before I'd
gone through SPO and I was like oh I
want to do get out of debt but I also
want to buy this handbag I also want to
go on vacation so I knew about you and
you know at that point that's when I
really fully committed to it so when the
student is ready the teacher will appear
again that's funny so did you go back
for FPU then you know I didn't know
mater I knew what I knew what to do and
I would listen to your podcast every day
when I work out at the gym mm-hm and
that really kept me focused and on track
and hearing the debt-free screams really
motivated me which is a big reason why I
wanted to make sure mm-hmm I came here
so hopefully I could be that story for
someone else you are you are awesome how
old are you I'm 34 34 33 I took a year
off dating isn't that crazy
yeah 33 that's okay it's alright this
it's all gonna work out I believe it
well yeah no question about it yeah I
mean because wow this is impressive
I mean you're making 120 thousand a year
you're killing it you knock out 37,000
all over the debt in nine months you
strike me as someone that is pretty
goal-oriented and when you decide to do
something there's not really anything
that stops you it's like get out of the
way there be bodies is that right you're
right great that's usually the kind of
person that can do this kind of thing on
straight Commission to make this kind of
income so you know how to drive the lane
put the ball in the hoop even if you're
not got somebody down to get it done not
that you're a mean person I don't mean
that at all but I mean you're just a
very task-oriented
so once you decided to do this the
switch flipped is that how it works
exactly what what's the hardest part
then I think because once you said game
owned it was on it was on I think
there's a few things that were hard but
the hardest thing was you know I'm
single and I live alone and especially
just getting out of a relationship where
you know you're spending a lot of your
time with someone it was kind of lonely
and Italy
and not really allowing myself much
money to spend on fun you know and you
know so what I figured out is you know I
would go for hikes with friends and
instead of going out for lunch
afterwards we would pack a picnic and
just enjoy each other's company but it
was still hard I'm not gonna lie
especially being a single one of coached
people years ago when I did a lot of
one-on-one coaching singles would often
tell me they would spend money on what
they called loneliness spending just to
get out and be near humans and to make
sure I wasn't trapped in the apartment
kind of thing and somehow that's
associated spending money it doesn't
have to be you just said you can go
hiking free you know but but somehow
there's that connectivity I've got to be
somewhere even if I'm not even a
conversation I just want to be near
humans you know it's and and you can
really spend a lot of money on that if
you're not careful so that's very
interesting so what are the keys to
getting out of death then I think you
know like you said I am a goal-oriented
person and very early on in my career I
learned from a mentor of mine that if
you fail to plan you plan to fail mm-hmm
and for some reason I hadn't yet it
really applied that to my financial life
but once I did just that power of
intentionality and having that level of
focus and just making that your
number-one financial goal next to giving
I think that was key is having the plan
sticking to it and then you know
tactically speaking of course doing a
written budget monthly mmm and you know
staying really committed that was cute
very cool well congratulations are very
proud of you we've got a signed copy of
Chris Hogan's retire inspired number one
best-selling book for you that will take
you to the next level last on the next
part of your story and you will you move
on now into building wealth serious
wealth and being in a position to you
know to completely be outrageously
generous and it's a different kind of a
world live in when you get yourself
there and you're well on your way very
proud of you congratulations yeah you
guys I bet you got some folks in your
life that are standing back going
smiling and going look at Michelle she
did good
I do yeah very good all right Michelle
from Denver Colorado 30
$7,000 paid off in nine months making
120 a year count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one I'm not
free yeah well done well done well done
that's awesome
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or $500,000 in common